one of the great things about creating a
sprawling cinematic universe with dozens
of characters is that the inevitable
storyline mistakes made along the way
don't have to be permanent stop
listening just like in the comics that
came before them each new chapter in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is an
opportunity to reach back into the past
clarify plot lines and close plot holes
and that's just what the minds behind
Avengers infinity wars say they did on
the revealing commentary track for the
epic 19th movie in the MCU warning
massive spoilers ahead directors Joe and
Anthony Russo sat down with co-writers
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
to break down how they wrangled 10 years
worth of buildup into one cohesive
climax there are a ton of great insights
into lingering questions about the
two-and-a-half hour blockbuster
including what has long been considered
a plot hole in the very first Avengers
flick from 2012 written and directed by
Joss Whedon you remember the scene
Natasha Romanoff Tony Stark and Steve
Rogers have Loki in custody on the
Avengers Quinn jet when all of a sudden
Thor crashes down like lightning Knox
start to the floor grabs his bro and
bails
but how did Thor actually get to earth
from Asgard when he destroyed his
typical mode of space travel the
rainbow-colored Bifrost bridge at the
end of the first Thor movie remember
Avengers takes place before the events
of Thor the dark world so the bridge had
yet to be rebuilt Thor doesn't explain
how he made it to earth in the first
Avengers outing but Loki assumes it has
something to do with dark energy with
the Bifrost gone how much dark energy
did the all-father have to muster to
kunji you here you all press us in the
infinity war commentary track co-writer
Christopher Markus says crediting dark
energy for the trip always seemed like
quote a bit of a paste job sorry just so
they added a callback in infinity war to
bolster it the comment comes during an
early infinity war scene when the Hulk
beaten badly by fan oohs in one-on-one
combat gets magically beamed back to the
earth by the Asgardian Heimdall the
former guardian of the Bifrost
Heimdall's use of dark magic which comes
right before his ultimate sacrifice
allows the Avengers to have some crucial
time to prepare themselves before Thanos
his arrival which makes all the
difference in their ability to resist
his invasion as much as they do
addressing unnamed critics who called
the whole magical dark energy
explanation from the first Avengers
movie ochite Marcus says Heimdall
summoning of dark magic an infinity war
can now be seen as clear evidence that
Loki's assumption was correct you just
saw where the dark magic came from
straight out of Heimdall thankfully this
vague dark energy travel is no longer
necessary for Thor who is more than
capable of bridging the cold expanse of
space on his own by the end of infinity
war his new Bifrost summoning axe
Stormbreaker is his new ride bringing
him to a Conda for the film's
devastating climax and he'll need it for
what's ahead in the still untitled
Avengers 4 due out may 2019 which rumor
has it will feature at least one time
travel or flashback scene straight out
of the original Avengers flick so expect
your understanding of the events of that
film to shift yet again Avengers
infinity war will be out on 4k blu-ray
standard blu-ray and DVD on August 14th
if you're itching to hear the full
commentary track it's available as a
digital download from select outlets
[Music]